battlefield 2042 is a game about a
disastrous future where humans have
pretty much screwed the pooch on the
environment and smaller nations are
falling apart shedding stateless
soldiers who are then swept up into
these larger proxy wars what a great
time to be alive but seriously
battlefield's really just about doing
wild things in helicopters jeep stuff
crazy gadgets and having fun so let's
get you caught up on everything you need
to know hit that subscribe button and
give us the old thumbs up let's get to
it
specialists let's start with the most
recent information and honestly the most
controversial in the community at
release 2042 has 10 playable specialist
characters with more coming in
post-launch seasons these specialists
replace the older class system and they
fall very loosely under those old
categories like assault and engineer
each sport a unique gadget called a
specialty and has a unique trait unlike
the old class system loadouts are fully
open meaning players can choose whatever
weapon they want and they can also pick
a support item or a rocket launcher and
also bring along a grenade many of these
support items like ammo crates were
previously locked behind classes here
are the first 10 specialists starting
with the two support characters we have
maria falk dubbed danger grandma by the
community poor lady already got a big
nerf in the alpha so she can't revive
players from a distance anymore but her
surret pistol can still heal at range or
more importantly heal herself her trait
combat surgeon means she revives players
off the ground to full health she also
got some recent buffs after the open
beta so her surret pistol fires more
sticky darts that home in on players
more easily and she revives more quickly
then there's constantine angle also
known as angel who can drop loadout
crates that allow players to swap their
weapons as well as pick up armor and
ammo when he revives downed players his
trait trauma specialist means that he
also reveals their bonus armor and
health it's speculated this character
will be very useful in hazard zone then
there's three assault specialists
starting with webster mckay who by far
had the most used gadget of the open
beta the grappling hook and sports the
nimble trait that allows him to move
more quickly than other players while
aiming down sights he can grapple onto
way more things than you think which we
covered in our 21 things every
battlefield player should know video
then there's emma also known as sundance
affectionately dubbed the flying
squirrel by the community they have the
wingsuit trait that lets them glide
between objectives and get maximum use
out of tornadoes they're one of the few
characters whose trait is probably
stronger than their specialty which is
smart explosives a multi-purpose grenade
that can even take down helicopters then
their santiago dozer espinoza with his
ballistic shield that can be used as a
battering ram something we haven't seen
yet and to tank enemy fire or even
reflect those bullets back to complement
his style dozer's blast resistant trait
means you can't just back up and handle
them with a grenade next up the
engineers piotr guskovsky also known as
boris whose main thing is a sentry gun
that automatically spots targets and
mildly perturbs them with bullets at
least that's how it works in the open
beta in order to make the sentry
effective boris can use his passive
trait sentry operator also known as
standing next to it next kimball irish
graves sports a fortification system
which is a type of deployable cover and
he can use the aps-36 to take down
incoming explosive projectiles his
passive trade veteran means that when he
runs over downed enemies he gets more
armor the three recon soldiers are
naveen rau with his cyber warfare suite
that scrambles enemy vehicle electronics
can disable rangers and trigger some
environmental obstacles like raising
bollards his trojan network trait allows
him to hack an enemy and then take them
down to reveal other nearby enemies
wikis casper vendeel is the most similar
to the traditional recon class in
battlefield and has the third most used
specialty of the open beta which is the
recon drone this drone is handy for
spotting enemies designating targets for
lock-on weapons and disorienting
vehicles with an emp blast his trait
movement sensor is very strong and
alerts players of any approaching
enemies then we have jisu pake probably
with the most controversial ability so
far because it's basically a wall hack
pake's emg x scanner reveals enemies
behind cover and then highlights them in
red her trait threat perception also
highlights enemies that shoot at her
maps so where will you be playing with
these specialists battlefield 2042
launches with seven new maps and six
remastered classic maps that are pulled
from 1942 bad company 2 and battlefield
3. new locations have been added to some
of these old areas such as a low tide
zone on valparaiso that's to accommodate
the full 128 players on pc and next gen
consoles these maps can only do up to 64
players on xbox one and playstation 4.
the new maps are some of the biggest in
battlefield history breakaway for
example is 5.9 square kilometers that's
significantly larger than el alamein a
huge map from battlefield 1942 maps will
have random extreme weather events show
up like tornadoes that can lift and toss
players and vehicles as they go many of
the maps will have set-piece events
occur such as orbital with its rocket
launch hourglass with its sandstorm and
discarded which hides a nuclear
submarine inside the hull of a behemoth
of the ship overall destruction seems to
be on par with battlefield 3 meaning you
can blow out the walls of smaller
buildings but we haven't seen any fully
collapsible structures yet and most
larger buildings can't be destroyed
campaign battlefield 2042 will not have
a campaign but it will tell a story
through its website seasons cinematics
in-game environmental storytelling such
as radios and in-game voice lines an
example of this is how irish was
featured in the exodus short film he's
played by the talented michael k
williams who sadly passed away this year
his story gave us both a very personal
and larger overarching plot that players
can engage with or ignore high level the
united states and russia are on the
brink of war and there's a secret piece
of information floating around out there
that would get the conflict started the
two main characters irish and oz are
both non-patriotic people who are people
with no citizenship or country they both
want to help the nopat community but in
vastly different and opposing ways irish
wants to hide this information to stop
an all-out war because he hopes major
countries will come to accept
non-patrioted people and fears many of
them would die in a full conflict
including his own non-patriotic son oz
on the other hand seeks to release the
information intending to ignite a major
war because he feels nopats will be
forgotten and left behind a rot unless
they're needed to fight the exodus
trailer ends with a call to action for
players to go to the doha map and
participate in the plot somehow
modes so what does all this mean what
will you actually be doing battlefield
2042 sports three modes all out warfare
hazard zone and portal player counts do
vary in some of these modes but as
covered before pc and next gen consoles
can go up to 128 players and xbox one
and ps4 are limited to 64. there are
bots that will fill into the larger
matches if needed and players can play
against just bots if they want to
practice all out warfare is the main
battlefield experience and consists of
conquest and breakthrough conquest sees
players fighting over flags grouped into
sectors and will evolve both fast and
slow paced moments one of the bigger
changes to conquest is just how spread
apart sectors can be on some of the maps
meaning enemies can be fully pushed out
of an area allowing a quiet moment where
the winning team has some time to
regroup breakthrough divides teams into
attackers and defenders where attackers
capture sectors and push back the front
line this mode is designed for constant
engagement hazard zone is the more
intimate high stakes squad based mode
and takes place on the seven new maps of
the game unlike all out warfare's 128
player account hazard zone only sports
32 or eight teams of four this is also
the only mode that prevents teams from
choosing duplicate specialists the goal
is to locate data drives from satellites
that fall across the map and then
extract them to waiting aircraft those
aircraft only show up twice a match and
at randomized locations the longer
players survive the greater the rewards
and also the greater the risk players
only have one life but they can be
brought back by their team using the
reinforcement uplinks or purchase back
with the in-game currency called dark
market credits this currency is earned
each round and used in-game or in
preparation phases of the following
round to buy advantages called tactical
upgrades it also sounds like some areas
of the map will be guarded by occupying
forces which means player first player
versus environment finally there's
portal which is more of a content
creation tool than anything else portal
pulls armies weapons vehicles and maps
from several older battlefield titles
and then lets players fight them in
their own custom matches these can be
made very simple by just locking out
certain guns and attachments in vehicles
or they can be made very deep using a
logic editor the only limitation is that
players can't mix armies on a single
team and apparently they can't make
their own battle royale game at least
not on a big map progress will carry
over from portal to the other game modes
however dice has said they put some
safeguards in place to prevent players
from grinding xp in unfair ways portal
will also allow players to go back and
play some older maps with features they
never had before like 1942's l alamein
with enhanced visuals destruction and
128 players to keep things a bit more
organized dice will feature a rotating
series of games that are built by the
community and personally i'm just
looking forward to original bad company
2 maps largely untouched except for 128
players
[Music]
new gameplay mechanics the two biggest
changes to gameplay and battlefield are
the colin tablet and the plus system
starting with the plus system for the
first time in battlefield you can swap
weapon attachments in real time this is
incredibly versatile letting players do
things like change scopes to engage at
different ranges and even swap ammo
types to impact weapon handling and
damage output then there's the colin
tablet used in both all-out warfare and
hazard zone this mechanic allows players
to airdrop in vehicles and attack robot
dogs in any open area of the map which
is ideal given the map size so players
don't get stranded in hazard zone the
tablet is used to bring squad makes back
to life after you collect reinforcement
uplinks
battlefield 2042 has four content
seasons planned each lasting about three
months and there will be a battle pass
each season will add new specialists and
push the overarching narrative forward
there will be a free and paid for battle
pass that will include microtransactions
the game has cross progression and cross
purchase so you can take your stuff to
different platforms minus a few
exclusive items we've already caught a
glimpse of some of the cosmetics that
can be earned or purchased and they come
in common rare epic and legendary
versions
[Music]
battlefield 2042 has an early access
release on november 12th and a general
release with a day one patch on november
19th we're here to cover it all
including a review things you might not
know and wild mode you come up with in
portal so head on over to gamesbot's
youtube page thanks for watching
you